GIL STRANG: Typically, the
first few days of class,
these guys ask what's the
class average going to be?
How are we going to be graded?
I don't have any
answers for that stuff.
So I say what is totally
true, that I don't feel
my main job is to grade them.
My job is to teach them
or learn with them.
That's what I continue to
do, and gradually, they
begin to believe.
SARAH HANSEN: Today
in the podcast,
we're talking with teaching
legend Professor Gil Strang.
GIL STRANG: Maybe the key
point is that make it human.
You're a person like
the student is a person.
The book isn't quite a person,
but it was written by a person.
SARAH HANSEN: Welcome
to Chalk Radio,
a podcast about inspired
teaching at MIT.
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen,
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
One of OCW's most
popular courses
is Professor Strang's
18.06 Linear Algebra,
a key foundation for his new
course on machine learning,
in which he's teaching
students to teach computers.
Professor Strang is known
for inspiring students
through his teaching.
One YouTube commenter
sums it up well.
Quote: "This is not lecture.
This is art."
We wanted to talk
with Professor Strang
to see how he's been able to
make complex math concepts
engaging and accessible.
We'll pick up our conversation
with his explanation
of what his new course,
18.065 Matrix Methods in Data
Analysis, Signal Processing, and
Machine Learning is all about.
GIL STRANG: So this
is my adventure
into the subject
of deep learning.
For example,
recognizing an image,
recognizing a zip code,
a bunch of numbers,
translating languages,
or playing chess,
so that's what the
course is about.
How does the machine learn?
Essentially, the idea
is say take an image,
then the deep learning
system leads the machine
to look at the examples.
We all learn from examples.
The machine learns
from examples,
and from many examples,
or many chess games
or many pages of Chinese,
you learn what's happening.
And what the math part is is
that the machine ultimately
tries to assign a certain
weight to a certain number,
big or small, to each
part of the image.
So perhaps, if you're
drawing a three,
the computer recognizes a
three, of course, by the curves
and gives less weight,
or zero weight sometimes,
to the empty space around the
three but picks out that three.
So that's the idea
of deep learning.
SARAH HANSEN:
Traditionally, math courses
have been defined by testing,
which honestly makes sense.
There's typically a right
and a wrong answer in math.
If you know the operation,
if you do it right,
you should get the answer.
Tests can be a great vehicle
for strengthening and measuring
students' skills, but Professor
Strang's approach is different.
GIL STRANG: So I ask
everybody to do a project.
There is no final exam.
Actually, there
is no exam at all.
I shouldn't like
say this, but that's
really what the subject is
is having an idea of how--
OK, I'll use deep
learning for some thing.
Like the recent proposed
project was can you identify
what makes an image or
a picture attractive?
SARAH HANSEN: Hmm.
GIL STRANG: So
somebody has to say,
these pictures are attractive.
These are not.
We have to tell the
computer something.
SARAH HANSEN: What did
that feel like to try
something new, pedagogically?
GIL STRANG: Oh, it's fun.
I like teaching, and this
is a subject where students
just come from everywhere.
Because they know
what stuff to learn,
and they've heard about it.
And some of them
know more than me,
and then those students
write even better projects.
Yeah.
So I do the lectures for
the first three quarters
of the course, and then I try
to get them to present which
is a great experience for them.
So it takes a little
urging to get them,
but yeah, it's really
just wonderful.
SARAH HANSEN: What
insights have you
gained about having more
of a student-led course
and a project-based course?
GIL STRANG: You realize,
slowly but finally,
that that's how people
learn, by doing.
You couldn't give them
a better way to learn
than create a project.
Usually it's on some
topic they know about
or they they're interested in.
Like how do you find a
criminal in a bunch of people?
Yeah.
It's a very effective
way to learn,
and it's something
that gets remembered.
Where doing exam questions
that I might make up,
sort of mathy
questions, I don't know
if that's remembered
10 years later,
but I think people's
projects are.
SARAH HANSEN: Along
with this new approach
comes a new paradigm for
measuring student learning.
Projects involve more than
right and wrong answers.
Projects are subjective, and
bringing the subjectivity
into a math course comes
with some initial skepticism,
especially from students who
are so used to the typical
"learn the subject, perform on
the test" way of doing things.
One of the things
that makes Professor
Strang and his
courses so special
is that he's not attached
to these paradigms.
In 18.065, in one
of the videos, you
talk about grading
students' work.
GIL STRANG: Yeah.
SARAH HANSEN: And you tell
them that, although this
is important, to
grade their work,
it's not your main concern.
That your main concern is
actually learning with them.
GIL STRANG: Right.
SARAH HANSEN: Could you talk
a little bit about that?
GIL STRANG: Yeah.
That's right.
So typically, the first few
days of class, these guys
ask, what's the class
average going to be?
How are we going to be graded?
I don't have any
answers for that stuff.
So I say what is totally
true, that I don't feel
my main job is to grade them.
My job is to teach them
or learn with them,
and that's what
I continue to do,
and gradually they
begin to believe.
At the beginning,
they still think,
OK, but he's got to give
me a B or C or an A,
but really that's not what
18.065 is about, a grade.
It's just not.
Math is something you do.
You don't just read.
You have to do it.
You have to think about it.
The way to learn math
is to get into it
and work on a thing
which takes some thought.
You don't see it immediately,
but you see it eventually.
SARAH HANSEN: One of
my favorite takeaways
from Professor Strang's approach
is that he centers his lessons
around the humans in his class.
For him, it's about engaging
with the students in his course
as people, and the learning
is done by everyone.
GIL STRANG: Well, first, I like
students, and I want to help.
And maybe the key point
is to think with them,
not to just say, OK, here it is.
Listen.
Listen up.
I think through the question
all over again, as they do,
and you have to give time.
You can't zip through a
proof, because the class
has to be thinking with you.
And it happens that
I lose the thread,
or I come up to a dead
end, where I don't know
what I'm supposed to do next.
But well, that's
OK, because students
are going to hit dead ends.
So it seems to me it's OK for me
to get stuck too and then given
they see, oh, OK,
maybe this is the way
to get out of that corner.
I suppose, I try to think
it through once again,
and then you automatically
see the word.
You recognize what
words you need to use
and what the steps are.
Yeah.
If you're not
thinking it yourself,
then you're probably
going too fast
and not connecting with
the thinking of the class.
And of course, you don't
know what everybody
is thinking in that
class, but overall,
if you stay conscious
of the class,
conscious of where they are.
That's I think the
same for any speaker
is to be conscious
of the audience,
and it's maybe the key
point is to make it human.
You're a person, like
the student is a person.
The book isn't quite
a person, but it
was written by a person,
and to see that it's just
like a natural thing to do.
Yeah.
So essentially, I think the
thing is, I like students,
I like math, and putting
them together is just
the best job in the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: Professor Strang
shares additional thoughts
on teaching linear algebra
and matrix methods and data
analysis, signal processing
and machine learning
in videos within the
Instructor Insights sections
of his OCW courses.
You can find them
at ocw.mit.edu.
While you're there, download
the teaching resources
from his courses, and
watch his lecture videos.
Discover the magic of his
teaching for yourself.
We're so happy to bring you
conversations with MIT faculty
who are passionate
about impacting
the world in positive ways.
Write to us to share
your story of how
you're using OCW materials
to shape your world or those
of others.
Until next time, I'm Sarah
Hansen from MIT OpenCourseWare.
[MUSIC PLAYING]